[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to bleacher reports pregame
picks the show where you
the people at home can win free cash
prizes that's right we're giving away
four thousand dollars tonight and all
you have to do is go on the bleacher
report app
and put in your pre-game picks we're
just going to go over the random [ __ ]
that occurs in
nba pregames and give away free money
usually i would be with my famous ass
co-host drewski
he should be here soon he's so hollywood
he's running late but that's okay
we're gonna get to these pics and give
out the money let's get it
the game show this is where it's at man
let's get to these picks my boy
let's do it boom i told you he's showing
off the money with this look
let's get it
so like i said in the intro today uh
we have drewski running a little late
i'm riding solo as y'all know but that's
okay we still got a lot of money to give
you guys
four thousand dollars we'll be giving
out tonight to the people who got in on
bleach report app and put in those
pre-game pics
so let's take a look at tonight's
prompts and challenges
number one what will my guy alonzo ball
rock to the arena i cannot wait to see
that one
i'm a fan a underrated fan of what lonzo
wears to the games
at number two the shoe king pj tucker
what brand will pj tucker wear tonight
that's always a mystery
because he has a lot of piss leave over
or under three and a half diane dunks in
her warm-ups
y'all let me know how y'all feeling
about that and then last but not least
the final shot of the rockets warm up
make or miss
that's gonna be a tough one as well we
gotta we got a nice uh little setup
going on
nice little little little thing a little
action uh my favorite one i think i'm
gonna go with the zion the zion dunks i
don't know how zion does with pre-games
i don't know if he's a dunker or is he
trying to shoot be sexy cool
that's been a mystery uh last episode
james harden did us dirty
but like i said challenge one what will
lonzo ball be wearing to the pre-game
i can't wait to see here are the
contestants
so the people at home that may
potentially be taking home 200
what did they vote for so we have the
hoodie we have the jacket
we have the sweater and we have high
fashion
i want to give a big shout out to my guy
brian miller6
i believe that's a fan of my podcast so
shout out to bry hopefully lonzo wears
the
hood the sweater so you can get some
money but yes
these are the people that potentially
can take home 200
tonight simply by putting in their
pre-game pick on that bleacher report
app
if you're new make sure you're doing it
let's see some of lonzo's past
wardrobe entrances please
like i said man lonzo is very underrated
with the swag you know it reminds me of
myself you know a little grown man type
your dig
mixed with some of the the young flavor
you see the jacket going on right there
this right here plain
plain but sometimes plain works i think
that white t
is probably no less than a gram so i
don't want to put any disrespect on
lonzo's name that's probably definitely
high fashion right there don't get him
twisted
or confused this right here is a
sophisticated look
you know the button up button all the
way to the top that's why i like to wear
my collars you know what i'm saying
shout out to woody she want me to
unbutton
one or two over my stylist but you know
all the way up to the top is the way to
go
team light skin y'all already know lonzo
what we got next
something something simple you know
hooper hooper attire
the hoodie and the sweats nothing crazy
but like i said
with the white t it's something probably
worth more than everything that i got on
so no disrespect to lonzo's name but you
got to be comfortable when you feel good
you play good
so i'm digging that with lonzo now let's
see
what we have from lonzo tonight and his
interest and who's going to be taking
home
the 200 what we got lonzo rocking
tonight
boom so okay can we get i need a rewind
that was a little fast i don't know
how we're going to categorize this
because i don't think we have shirt
as an option
so we rewind with my eyes
if we can pause right here can we pause
right here
everybody at home if you look close you
can see the button ups we don't have a
button up option
so this one is going to fall on the high
fashion this is just a high fashion
button-up shirt so i believe anybody
that's picked high fashion should be a
winner
to me this is high fashion the boy got
velvet on his back
and boom we got drewski late as hell
but that's okay that's okay we got my we
got we got my guy getting ready but
that's okay
we're gonna focus on lonzo in this high
fashion that he wearing
um while drew ski is getting ready i
love lonzo that's my dog but those pants
he's flooding
i'm not a big player and i've been ready
they told me i was paying money today so
i showed up late on purpose
they poster has said but anyway
we got some winners taking home 200 with
high fashion shout out to my boy brian
miller that did pick the sweater
unfortunately brian you won't be taking
home 200 a day instead that's going to
humble slat 20. we got somebody by the
name of humble slat
shout out to thugger thugger drewski was
popping bro come on man
what's up man what's the deal how are we
living you here
i'm living good i'm here i got the
rollie on yeah yeah yeah yeah
we live from this dude man
that boy got the rollie on live from new
orleans my boy
drew ski came in with the rolly on uh we
got the pelicans tonight he don't even
know who playing he's so damn hollywood
look at him
yeah no no i told you
they were talking about that i was
giving out money i said hold up now
let's take a break hey i don't know i
don't know why you said hold up you got
through it
anyways since you late here are the
three game prompts man
these are the pre-game prompts okay
since you missed the the intro
we got what would lonzo wear to the
arena we already saw what he wore
it was high fashion in case you missed
it next we got with shoe brand with pj
tucker
um yeah you did oh okay i forgot you got
his number you is hollywood look at you
we got the over under on zion dunks
and then we got last but not least final
shot of the
rockets warm up make or miss i'ma get to
you juicy don't think we done
do not think we're done but up next we
got pj tucker shoes what brand will pj
tucker wear
hey broomski we got a piece for you
right now about pj tucker the shoe king
and how his shoe [ __ ] goes so check this
out okay
let's see how much do you need
pj getting out of hand man bro
come on bro what
so there you all see he has to wear it
every game
every game man the man got more shoes in
his locker than i have had in my entire
life and i'm a shoe guy
i mean it's kind of it's how much how
much is he getting paid a year man
uh that's a great question pj tucker
what are you making about nine meal
that's a that's a rough guess okay pj
tucker got some great
good meal he might spend a good meal on
shoes though
oh oh he might spend more than a meal if
we being honest
he might spend more more than a meal god
i mean
some of these shoes
like look at those i don't even know
what those are kicks those are kobe's
those are kobe's that was some crazy i
know they kobe strewski
but like what what what kobe's are they
what's the name are they cotton candy
are they cotton candy what's the name of
those kobe
they can't find them dandy it was a lot
of colors on those shoes yeah go back to
those shoes
towards the end
can we see the ones towards the end
the cotton candles look at that boxes
and pockets
hey we got people on the streets of
chicago with no shoes on their feet cold
they feet cold and frozen pj tucker
donate some shoes to my people in
chicago we got people walking around
downtown with no shoes crosstails feet
let's get some shoes donated you had
those kobe's are you lying
these are the ones i was talking about
right here okay the cotton candy i'm
calling them the cotton candies
they said those pes personal
additions though man i wouldn't go for
that man
how much you paying for those what's the
most what's the most expensive shoe that
you have in your collection let's talk
kicks man
let's talk kicks while we wait for pj
tucker let's talk
kicks man oh i actually i got one if
y'all
if y'all watched my uh sneaker shopping
on youtube
i bought the travis two thousand
dollars i have never in my life spent
that much on shoes
ever ever ever ever ever shut up my mom
got mad and was like
my mom got mad and said why the hell are
you spending that on shoes you could
have got
the whole family some kicks for a
hundred dollars a piece that
that's a lie that's a lie your mom ain't
say that because you're not what
are you rich no no no
what the [ __ ] who is it who told you
this stuff
man juicy is rich y'all
juice gets rich that's right he's giving
out four thousand dollars today
he's paying for two thousand dollar
shoes he's at the bahamas instead of
being here on time with me the man is
rich
i think i was in the bahamas recently
though man
because i snuck in your suitcase i was
out there too got a little saying
how much do you know okay okay i know i
i know a lot man i know who you was out
there with what you were doing out there
you know what i'm talking about
hey now all right now yeah
yeah you better slow your road i know
what you was out there doing
uncle p everywhere you want to go
what's the next pregame we're waiting on
we're waiting on the players to come out
juicy the next pregame pick is right
there what shoe brand will pj tucker
wear tonight
can we wait for the players to make a
niche i want to know how this weekend
was how was your weekend super bowl
sunday
talking weekend how was it weekend was
crazy man
uh went out there vibed with the whole
ovule team you know
it was definitely fun we had fun you
know a lot there's not too many people
in the bahamas right now because the uh
the covert stuff though oh you was out
there with over here
all right i was supposed to go out there
but i had i had something to do
yeah i called you i kept calling you and
you just you didn't pick up yeah
yeah cause you're drinking like bro i
need you here and i was like no
i had told 40 that i was going to be
over there but they wanted me over there
so i was like tell you
to go for me yeah yeah yeah right so i
appreciate you going for me because you
know
when i don't be going if you keep
calling it i kept calling i called i
called i called
i said man he ain't gonna make it and
you missed your flight
you still got my number from sixth grade
i changed my number
twice since then okay see now you just
no remember we had that class with miss
williams
you used to always get in trouble in
miss williams class why everybody
everybody had a miss williams [ __ ]
everybody had a miss williams
miss williams just to be on your ass
cause you always used to be talking
but now while we wait here's a reminder
of the pre-game picks that we have for
tonight lonzo will be rocked to the
arena we already saw here at the high
fashion button up
we're still waiting on what shoe brand
pj tucker will wear for tonight
we got the over or under on three and a
half dunks from zion and warm-ups and
then last but not least
final shot of the rockets warm-up make
or a miss
now we got the houston houston rockets
coming out
i need you to tell me what shoe is pj
wearing what are you rocking bro cause i
can't see i had my glasses on
they all came out in hoodies man god
damn
okay i can tell you right now from
looking at it
they need to pan that camera down damn
yeah the camera got to go and look down
y'all focus on his bald head
he got a pair of cortez those are nikes
those are cool kobe she was right those
are kobe's man not cortez
who the hell hoops and cortez
i thought that boy had a pair of nike
cortezers on man
oh are they cortez so pj tucker wear the
kobe's of course we should have known
i we should have known drewski that he
was wearing those are clean though those
are clean though
we should we should have not you
probably got them don't you you ain't
got them do you
no i ain't got i ain't got those
oh man 200 dollars
okay they knew nike hey give a shout out
to one of these winners
when you give them a shout out they feel
better okay i want to give a shout out
i want to give a shout out to kenzo's
dad
you know why because your dad's a legend
i don't know who the hell you is kenzo
but your dad brought you here yeah you
need to be thankful
so get up 200
shout out to kenzo man hey again a
reminder if you want to win 200
all you have to do is get on the beach
report game beats report app
get on pre-game picks put in your pick
of what pj tucker will be wearing
we got all type of random [ __ ] like that
and you can win two hundred dollars
drew's be giving away
four thousand dollars tonight the man is
rich
rich boy said my boy he gonna give out
four thousand dollars
hey hey zion got four thousand
for chauffeur show yep for sure he gives
us in the whole stack yeah
because from from jordan he got about 50
of them things i believe
i'm not mistaken 20 or 50. that's just
from jordan
rookie contract he may be making between
five or seven you know five or seven
so you know okay but the start of jordy
got four
jordan man
over under three uh
while we while we do this let's do let's
do something called
side action okay i want to put a sad
action thing
out here for you where
you guess we guess how many shots
lonzo makes in a minute you know i loved
how many shots in a minute okay
you know you know i love that okay so
can we get a camera shot of lonzo ball
i want the people at home to comment how
many shots they think lonzo can make
in 60 seconds i want to wait before we
start the clock let's give the people a
chance
at home let me know what they thinking
in those comments y'all put them y'all
let them comments go
and then in the meantime cameraman can
we get one more switch to zion let's
keep a track of zion dunks while we let
the people at home comment
how many shots of ball can make oh we
got a lot we got zion doing fake
stretches boy you know damn well when a
camera not rolling you're not doing that
right right he ain't even stretching
nothing that's a groin stretch right
there that's for the groin
desires arm and that's a groin
cut it out zion you know damn well when
the camera not on you don't be doing
this
that's his shoes that jordan right there
yeah those are shoes those drawers yup i
personally don't like them
but hey they cool for him i'm gonna keep
it real
keep it real one two one through ten
rate those for me
i need y'all in the comments are these
it are they not it it or not it please
please let me know i'm in the middle
about them i don't know
it's still jordan you know
no we can't do that we can't do that we
can't do because they don't look
comfortable now
but that's a powerful boy that's a
that's a southern boy right there
that's a big boy
so i don't oh man i i i don't think
i don't think he's looking for looks in
his shoes he got to make sure he
he can contain his pa you saw him bust
out of a shoe in college i know you saw
that
that shoe exploded
man i know you saw that i'm looking at
the shoes right now i'm still trying to
decide what my answer is
oh see i know what what's taking you so
longski
i forgot you are established superstar
you got connections you can't hurt your
connections with jordan
you don't have to answer brody i won't
let you i won't do you like that
i'm your manager now i'll represent you
hey
so we gonna change the subject we're
gonna put the clock up for lonzo
zhusky can i get an answer on how many
shots lions are doing in 60 seconds
before we start the clock how many you
got for me
how many he got
we ain't started yet we waiting on you
to give us
i say three uh nah i ain't gonna say
three i'll probably say like
seven seven okay i'm gonna go
four seven or four i'll give them seven
if i he's a shooter if i win
if i win i get to show up late next and
you got to lead the show
boom start the clock
it's already a deal
let me let me try to keep track of so
what's that is that's two
that's one okay we got one he definitely
ain't getting seven drews
he's going too slow that's two look out
he walking back
that's something i'm learning about this
as we do this i hear you texting that
way a superstar well odell won't
tell o'day i said what up
let me see man give me uh
how many he got right now already he got
three three [ __ ]
no no no you you already said sex i
don't shoot fast at all
oh my god he's still at three he's still
at three
come on zoe give me one more give me one
there it is god that's four take your
time zoe look sexy [ __ ]
yeah go talk to your teammate what's
going on how you been doing bro
how you was doing how you thank you very
much
yo that's my first god he's giving me a
first w
come on ball on the head falling ahead
can we get can we get that uh can we get
that zion cam cause i'm just
come on man you know this live you you
part of the show
you're the part of the show no
i want to know what odell wanted because
i know that's who you was texting
nah that ain't no deal i'll tell you who
it was
my momma asked him why i ain't picked my
drawers up man
hey richie 21 got it drewski i don't
know if you saw but ricky 21
he commented for richie 21
shout out to richie twain he know you
shout out richard yeah he said he know
you he said
y'all cuz i know a richard but i don't
know richard 21.
yeah he said you know hey richard 21 go
on the beach report app
check your dm so you can get that moolah
and then let us know what you are going
to do with that money
zion looks like he about to dunk brody
he's shooting jumpers
knowing damn well he don't do that in
the game but see zion don't got a timer
on his right
no he don't have the time on here okay
we need to put a dime on this
since he'll want to shoot jumpers we're
going to take a look we're going to take
a look at the contestants we got some
contestants
while zion is shooting jumpers um
junior baller shout out to junior baller
he's he's over
he's going over 3.5 and then we got
under
who i want to give a shout out i love my
wife i love my wife
i knew you was going there come on man
you know i love love juicy yeah
i love love valentine's day coming up
shout out to my girlfriend dana
we're gonna have a nice valentine's day
on the account of drew out to his
girlfriend
shout out his girlfriend dana shout out
his girlfriend yes sir
she's a good girl we're about to be
popular girl hey we bout to pop
we about to pop bottles on drewsky's
account shout out to drewski for the
4000.
you ain't feeling that bro
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey we got we got we got the timer going
for zion he got the last six minutes
to see if he gonna get the over uh under
oh what what the hell
i thought what what the what was that he
was about to come
hey he he's doing a lot of chilling so
again the bahamas broski i'm in chicago
it's cold i saw you on instagram posting
about it that's how i knew he was out
there it looked real fun man i hope you
enjoyed yourself
talk to me about it now it was fun come
on we were kissing
we bros
we we was just vibing you know we was uh
we had a uh a a boat day you know what
i'm saying we we was on the water
i almost drowned okay i had uh i had a
jet ski accident
that wasn't recorded that was the layout
real real out there
hey man don't don't don't be doing that
bro for the most part we
don't be drowning and stuff huh don't be
drowning and stuff
i need you don't be drowning i need you
oh yeah yeah damn right that's what i
said i thought
i thought she was i thought she was
encouraging to drown and i'm like hey
hold up [ __ ]
no no no no no no no no no no i need you
oh there you go
that's one oh my god he's laying it no
that's a yeah he's
he's stripping he's tripping he is
tripping he wanted them guys
he wanted them guys okay yo i used to be
one of those [ __ ] i could dunk
in high school but i used to always like
laugh and like just do a finger roll
no i remember that [ __ ] too man
no you had you regretted doing that
because remember you had tory your acl
when you was trying to dunk that one
time and i had helped you
i i had a meniscus
it's like a back leg tear right there
yeah
back leg there yeah ah still hurt when i
sit down with it
oh yeah see i i remember that though
we still um yeah we still got to see if
if if the rockets
uh warm up will end in the make or miss
we have some contestants that that put
in some pics for that
so that's coming up while we wait for
zion to do his thing a friendly reminder
always you can go on a bleacher report
app search for the pre-game pick so you
can give yourself a chance at home
to take home 200 me and juicy are giving
away four thousand dollars who don't
like earn money
listen you're sitting at home watching
me andrewski
your life is passing you back you're
saying maybe i'll do a pre-game
next week or next week no do it now we
wouldn't have all this
money and give it away you got to give
it back yeah that's a big
that's a fact man that's a fact if you
ain't if you ain't giving back to your
community you ain't doing nothing and
that's what we doing babe
me and drew's gonna give it away
that's when i knew he was a good dude
man when you gave me when you gave me
that 10 000
i knew hey don't speak on that bro you
was really down bad and sometimes i
don't want people to know about that
yeah
yeah i was [ __ ] up
hey i got you over there though man i
got your back no i know hey you know
that's over right i got your back like
cairo
pratt okay let's get that up
all right guys back to the dunks
[Laughter]
he's about to go
i don't even see him he's out there
shooting drunk oh i'll see okay i see
him now
i i'm i'm gonna be honest you know what
they might i'm a basketball guy go ahead
go ahead go ahead i'm a basketball guy
but this this annoys me a little bit
why do basketball players always act too
cool he know damn well he want to do a
dunk
right they like to laugh and do the
little the little shrug off the photo
like yeah
he knows he can't but they might
encourage him not to before games though
you know that's true that's true look at
true ski juicy got that gm mask what you
doing
now this is a question i'd be asking
it's a question i'd be asking a lot of
people about zion what you think about
his his
his athletic ability in the league like
how long do you think he could do this
now this is a young this is a young
black brother i'm wishing
i'm wishing 15 years of him to do this
but realistically
based off what i've seen uh
i'mma go three three and between three
and five
he's it's a lot it's a lot of weight
going on them needs i'm not gonna lie
but
we're not wishing anything bad on them
you know we want to see
no no no never that you know what i take
that back
15 15 years of zion doing it that that's
we're going to do we just going to put
it in the air last 20 seconds make her
miss
get what you got they ended with a make
or miss
oh man talk to me they ended with a make
now rockets could shoot then they
wouldn't make
i'm gonna go with you with that they
ended with a mate you gotta end with a
mate
shout out to our boy kyle roger he used
to always end on a mate
you know that when we was in high school
dude like it was
dude they missed bro they never missed
bro like
dude they normally don't ever miss
i'm freaking i'm so freaking upset that
he just missed dude i'm freaking
sick dawg that last shot i was
mad excited so dude because they missed
uh we're going to give away some money
to kirk williams
shout out to kirk oh you know what kirk
williams
yeah i did yeah my dad gave his dad
coach when i played uh
i had a coach kirk when i played uh
search league basketball
he's a good dude too anybody named kirk
you could trust him with money
so i think he's gonna do good dogs you
did not play in no
damn church league basketball wow
what position did you play come on
you trying to get a piece of shrimp
that's one cake
oh okay look at my boy yeah look at that
hard working man
he got a replay work man got a replay
was it a mate it pays off
yes it pays off
what type of cake is that man what type
of cake
come on man hey come on man don't be
sucking your fingers on camera he said
vanilla vanilla bean
vanilla bean vanilla bro you suck at
your
you sucking your fingers on camera ain't
we ain't gonna be doing that bro
we're not gonna be doing that bro that's
that's enough
nah we not doing that bro we not doing
that
here is the winning picks from
tonight's challenges and prompts again
lonzo rocking to the arena to the arena
high fashion let me close this one up
pj tucker where tonight ended up being
nike
over another three five zion dungeon
warmups
under three five final shots of rockets
warm-ups make a mess what you think it
was man just like you said
it was a mess hey i'm proud of you you
killed that
i'm doing pretty good
you a natural you a natural man yeah see
this will happen when you allow me
to take you under my wing and show you
the ropes of this oh
see now you getting disrespectful
hey no i just took you out of my wing go
ahead finish closing
tonight's winners tonight's winners go
ahead finish closing give us some shout
outs
tonight's winners shout out to my boy
joe poppy man shout out to my boy
jackson j shout out to my boy i love my
wife 67 you killing it man i need you to
give all this money to your wife tonight
and kirk williams give that money to
tithes and offering at church this
sunday brother
cause you a good dude yes sir shout out
to kirk man coach kirk we remember you
drew i like what you just did there bro
you did a real good job there man you
closed oh yeah
so what you're about to get into a truck
for that for valentine's day while we
talking
about what you're getting into i'm about
to report to cavacio
okay shout out to zoe shout out to pj
tucker
shout out to my boy drewski for showing
up he didn't leave me hanging
he didn't leave me
see you next week my lover
i love her for life
pregame pigs man
[Music]
you